john explain to me dungeons and dragons
because i don't understand you i was a
super geek but you were that's keeps to
the 10th power in high school
unfortunately i was doing it it wasn't
even like in junior high or like in et
they were playing it when they were like
eight years old how many guys were in
your game uh it varied everybody would
come over your house and we play in the
cafeteria at school and you have your
dice yes
and you throw the dice yes yes
and if you had like a 18 was good if you
had like a 18 strength then you'd be a
barbarian or a fighter or something so
you're strong or you'd have 18
intelligence and then you want to be a
wizard all right so now once the
character is determined your
intelligence is determined that's all
those things how does someone advance in
the story then there's a dungeon master
who's like the director of the movie but
it's not a movie it's a so would you get
a call from the dungeon master let's say
yeah he'd say
like how would it work did you have to
be there i got a call what is it what am
i a doctor how did you have to be
together you had to be together you're
sitting around a table with everybody
making fun of you because most of us
were overweight and not well groomed
okay so the dungeon master says deep in
the dark of the village well that would
be good if you did it like that they
would go like he'd have a map in front
of him yeah and he said give me a little
mood here we go
[Laughter]
the dungeon master say you see a cave
and the guy who plays the elf
thief says i'm going to walk up to the
cave what do i see
and he rolls some dice he says okay you
don't see anything you enter the cave
who's standing first who's second we put
the dwarf with the axe up front
then you also have these little figures
that look like your characters that you
put out on on the table in the middle of
the lunch room so everybody knows where
you're standing
right you get me this is crazy i'm i'm
shocked
so let's say so i come up to the cave
yeah i'm going with you on this i'm
there and i'm about to enter the cave i
roll the dice and it says i encounter an
elf or you encounter but probably
something bad like like a like a orc
let's say you're an orc
i'm not nowhere on the same team okay so
we encounter that how do we defeat him
with the dice you roll dice and you
swing your weapon and then the dungeon
master looks at his charts and sees
whether you kill him or not okay if i
don't kill him that means i'm killed it
could be yeah and then you roll up
another character and then i'm out of
the game then you start you roll up
another character and he joins the party
it's like a video game except without
the computer you are a brave man and i'm
going to tell you why i want to
compliment you when you were in that
dungeon and you were facing that elf
you rolled the dice i'm going to make a
movie about these elves
be careful when you leave because orc is
lurking outside the building
[Music]